Ukrainian soldiers defending bahmund
enter The Fray knowing they are
outnumbered
and more Russian Fighters are on the way
bakmut is the major Flashpoint on the
Eastern front right now Ukraine's
president has promised he won't let the
city fall without a fight
but Vladimir zielinski may also be
preparing his people for a worst case
scenario
in the course of 346 days of this War I
often had to say that the situation at
the front was tough and that the
situation was becoming tougher it is
once again that time
Ukraine's Army says it gunned down as
many as 200 Russian mercenaries from the
Wagner group in a recent attack but
Russian forces are gaining ground as
they push to surround the city the worry
for Kiev now Russia could be close to
successfully cutting off the main
Highway into the city currently
Ukraine's main supply line that could be
a decisive moment in the battle for
bakman
Russian missiles are also hitting more
civilian targets along the Eastern Front
air strikes in kharkiv hit a university
and a residential block
there was a strong blast and everything
happened so quickly we were saved by the
furniture that fell on us because of
that we are alive
she's only lived in kharkiv a few months
homeless and displaced for a second time
during this war
the siege of bakmut has emptied out the
city
but some refused to leave seeking refuge
in prayer
I know there is a chance I might die
last night a shelter into my garden all
the windows were blown out a bullet
Flint of my house this morning it could
have hit me in the head our life is
fleeting they will die in any case well
now or in 20 30 years it is not
important the main thing is how I
present myself to God
I pray for our country for our Ukraine
for my children for my family for all
ukrainians for all I pray
but will Ukrainian lines remain as
unbreakable as their faith
both likely to be tested in coming days
as Russian forces escalate their
campaign for bakmut Zayn basavi Al
Jazeera